another truck arrives at this farm in
the kiev region of northern ukraine
the rush is on to empty these silos of
last year's harvest of maize to make
space for approximately 35 000 tons of
winter wheat
but much of this crop may go to waste
because of what ukraine and many
countries it exports to say is a russian
sea blockade at least 20 million tons of
grain is already stuck in silos across
the country
contributing to rising prices and what
the un says is a growing global food
crisis
so this maze is being moved out of the
silos in order to make space
for the winter wheat harvest that is
expected to start in about a month from
now
a lot of this maze is being taken to
silos elsewhere but a lot of it will
begin its journey to a port in romania
a journey that can take up to three
months and is very complicated indeed
one route takes the grain by train from
kiev into moldova to avoid a coastal
road that ukraine says russian forces
have shelled
the train then drops back into the
odessa region of ukraine before being
unloaded at the romanian border onto
barges in renee and ismail
it then heads down the river danube to
the romanian black sea port of constanta
analysts say shortages and long overland
export routes have pushed the consumer
price of grain up in recent months
producers have been hit even harder
the cost of transport and logistics has
increased 300 since before the war
started we are also looking at ways of
getting the grain out via the baltic sea
and through hungary but it can also take
up to two months
before the trucks take the maze away
samples are analyzed at a quality
control laboratory on the farm
the grains will be periodically
inspected again in the coming weeks
because much of it will have to be
stored outside silos where rot could set
in after only a month
exporting by train from ukraine is
complicated because the rail track gauge
is different in neighboring poland and
romania
russian forces withdrew from this area a
few weeks ago
this wheat was planted before the war
started
farmers work in the fields of maize and
sunflowers despite the danger of mines
an unexploded ordnance
it was very difficult because we were
sowing
during the invasion
our domestic market is very small we
have to sell it
russia which is also a major grain
producer says western sanctions prevent
it from exporting to global markets
depriving it of billions of dollars of
revenue and making the crisis even worse
moscow says it is open to a potential
turkish and u.n plan to allow safe
passage for ships to transport grain
from ukrainian ports across the black
sea and out to international markets via
the bosphorus
but russia says ukraine must demine the
sea route first
ukraine has so far refused saying it
won't leave ukrainian ports like odessa
exposed to a potential russian attack
from the sea
no agreed solution means ukraine could
lose billions of dollars in revenue and
according to the un more countries
across africa and asia already suffering
food shortages could potentially suffer
even more john stratford al-jazeera kiev